here's what would happen if you survived
the end of the solar system okay let's
fast forward around one and a half
billion years things won't be looking
too good for life on Earth our
increasingly bright Sun would set off a
global warming Spike Earth would be so
hot our oceans would boil why well seven
and a half billion years from now our
sun will become a red giant it'll run
out of hydrogen fuel and start burning
helium instead our expanding sun will
vaporize Mercury burn Venus's atmosphere
and eventually swallow that planet whole
earth well it'll just be a hot iron core
at this point too much heat and
radiation from our sun would shift
liquid water out toward Mars we could
try living on Jupiter's moon Europa for
a few hundred million years but in about
10 billion years we'd need to find a
habitable exoplanet circling a different
star so